what promising new high-tech medical
device could help some people move away
from prescription painkillers the FDA
recently gave it the go-ahead 26 percent
of Americans who are 20 and older
reports some type of chronic pain every
day more than 650,000 prescriptions for
opioids are filled but 2 million
Americans are addicted to those
painkillers which often provide a
gateway to illicit drugs like heroin our
doctor Tara Narula is here with how a
drug free approach lets patients stop
the pain I love this woman you
interviewed she's so strong-willed she
is absolutely a good morning to you
chronic pain can affect every aspect of
patients lives preventing them from
working caring for family members or
even themselves it often starts in the
backer leg but it can quickly become
all-encompassing
doctors now have a new tool to help
decrease the perception of pain a small
implant placed in the back that can get
patients back on their feet
Connie Hanafy had a passion for riding
dirt bikes then minor leg surgeries
sidelined her with crippling pain I love
your picture steroid shots seizure
medications nerve blocks and physical
therapy did not bring relief Oh perfect
because of her own family history of
addiction Connie refused prescription
painkillers the pain was so unbearable
the single mother of two considered
amputating her leg the pain is constant
it's stabbing it's burning it's shooting
it's every type of pain you could ever
imagine
all in one then you're trying your best
but you're just screaming on the inside
because nobody can understand what
you're going through then Connie learned
about another option good morning a
spinal stimulator that zaps pain she
decided on surgery to implant the device
in her back that's a crime
[Music]
tell me when you feel this during the
first part of surgery she is sedated but
awake giving real-time feedback so the
stimulator wires can be placed in the
right spot on her spine how's it going
into photos final nerve stimulators use
electrical pulses to block the pain
signal to the brain they've been used
for decades but previous models were
bulky and needed frequent charging this
summer the FDA approved the smallest
implantable device about the size of a
pacemaker let me know as soon as you
start to feel it in the recovery room
Connie feels a tingling in her leg
[Music]
confirming the device is working to mask
the sensation of pain the majority of
patients will report at least 50%
reduction in pain Yousef Josephson is
one of the first doctors trained to
treat patients with Medtronic snoo
implant and this device has a tracking
component so you can monitor what
activity they're doing how is that
helpful to you what it allows us to do
is real-time follow that patient over a
period of time with their with in terms
of their functionality because
ultimately if they're still sitting on
the couch that's not what we want is
doctors we want them to be functional
and enjoying their lives this is really
what I want to get back to so the goal
is to get back on this yes two weeks
after surgery
Connie's pain has dropped from level
nine to two I really want to get active
slow down a little bit but I feel great
she has a long road ahead before she's
riding dirt bikes again but she's kept
her leg and has her life back so is
there something that you want other
people who might be suffering with pain
to know from your story prescription
medication although it does help people
that's not the only answer and if that's
not something you want to do seek out
other options
this implant does carry risks like
bleeding and infection and spinal cord
stimulators are not appropriate for
every kind of pain their best for people
with back and limb pain who may have
failed back or disc surgery and other
conditions about eighty eight thousand
have been implanted worldwide that's
expected to more than double in the next
decade
you have the prop here with you it
really is it's very small I mean this is
the device that gets implanted in the
back and these are the wires that get
implanted in the spine and this is the
device that the patient can use to
control the stimulation so very small so
to go from a level nine to two that's a
game-changer is that's a permanent fix
it can be the battery this part needs to
be changed about every nine years but
essentially it's otherwise permanent and
how much does it cost right so it's
about thirty thousand dollars for the
device that doesn't include the price of
the actual procedure but it is usually
covered by insurance so good news
something that people need to be aware
of to ask their doctor about it and it's
certainly worth the cost if the only
other option was amputation
that's right their products are opioid
or narcotics stay off that dirtbike
though